what's [ __ ] up is for some people
their experiences in high school define
them you know I just watched that a
Stephen King movie it the the most
recent one with the clown yeah pretty
[ __ ] good but what one of the things
that I was thinking when I was watching
it was like how [ __ ] mean kids are in
school to each other I guess you kind of
forget about that and then you watch one
of those movies about people being mean
to people you're like oh yeah I remember
going around to get away from a guy that
was picking on me that was [ __ ] with me
and like you would be scared of running
into him at the bus stop and scared of
seeing him after school that's how I got
into martial arts in the first place I
got tired of being scared scared of
people I was in martial arts when I was
still [ __ ] scared let me tell you
something funniest thing about the movie
it was that they [ __ ] with clowns so two
months later a bunch of clowns got
together one on strike they went
downtown and they had a parade like not
a parade
what do you call when people get
together and and they [ __ ] have signs
this is right after that movie was
released one thousand seventeen whenever
that movie was released a month later
two months later a bunch of clowns in
the in the California area got together
downtown and picketed Stephen King
because they were losing work as clowns
because they had lost a bunch of clowns
got cancelled they lost all their clown
season work or some [ __ ] I read the book
a long time which won it I remember I
was like man how are they gonna make a
movie out of this and they made a movie
out of it way back in the day with John
Boy from The Waltons I'm gonna do with
the mole on his face got a ponytail in
it I watched it the other night on TV
just flipping through the channels it
was on and was after a couple days after
I had seen the the most recent version
of it it was hilariously bad it was so
stupid but it was John Boy with the
Waltons and might have been how many
versions of that it movie did they make
that was just two the first one was the
first one with Tim the guy from the
Rocky Horror Picture Show that well that
was who the
yeah it was so stupid who sort of like
it wasn't scary at all
I mean that not even remotely but the
new one was pretty [ __ ] scary well
Stephen King dog is a [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] we both read on writing
yeah we both did you see my son's an
together
no he want me they contact from like we
want here to be on sons Alec he's like
listen the only way I'm gonna say
exactly they had to go back and forth
like we don't need user well I just tell
you if I go on Sons of Anarchy I gotta
ride my motorcycle so he played a creepy
guy that makes you disappear after they
kill you
really like he comes in and measures you
like you're on the floor dead and he
walked and measure you and tell you what
he needs
I need a rope I need some gasoline I
need a corporate car I also need a
selection of seventies classic rock and
then you disappear when you come back
there's nothing there and they walk him
out he tells you what you want how much
800 you pay in the 800 if you only have
six he'll look around the room he'll
just take like a statue
Taizo statue on the motorcycle he was
classic sons anarchy you know the crazy
thing about him was his battle coming
back from getting hit by that guy in a
car he was walking I think was in Maine
right
he was walking and some guy wasn't
paying attention and [ __ ] hit him in
his car just destroyed his body like
just destroyed his body like I mean he
was [ __ ] up for all the motorcycle
yeah shatters no no he was walking he
was just walking and we got hit by a guy
in a van token i read that i think you
turned me on to it when i read that
chapter on carry how he got written half
a carry and threw it away and his wife
found it you and him finish it and it
was about a girl with a paries of
something crazy and like I was in shock
great book Carrie is a great book right
Carrie and Cujo my favorite Stephen King
book
Kujo till this day I have it I look at
it and I respected it's like cocaine
this I don't even open that book I just
look at it and touch it from time to
time and I go oh I don't know if I want
to get into that thing it was a great
book that they did like the the the
movie version of it's like was Pet
Sematary Pet Sematary is a book there's
some things about books you know I hate
the cliche that books are better oh the
books better but what is interesting
about books is there certain things that
you shouldn't really see you should only
imagine like they were they work out
better in them I mean you're in your
imagination like there's something much
creepier about them in your imagination